next I'm in president from Scripps okay
thanks a lot yeah I know it's the talk
after lunch so I hope you've got enough
coffee and see that this is going to be
some light entertainment okay so this is
some joint work with my former graduate
student Elaine levy okay so this is
about one of the classical problems in
scheduling and here we go we have a set
of job and jobs Jay and first of all
things look look easy in the sense that
they they all have the same running time
of one so this happens the unit
processing time jobs and I have some
number M of machines and they're all
identical the only thing that makes the
problem nasty is that I have precedence
constraints so this is indicated like
this so it means that job index by one
has to finish before I can start with
job number three and my objective
function is I want to schedule the jobs
on those M and machines so that the the
makespan the time that the last job
finishes is minimized this is one one
example solution I think this is the
optimum solution so this is a schedule
of my 13 jobs so that the time the may
expand the time that the last job
finishes is is minimized and you can see
that I hope I didn't screw up
for example if you look at job 1 and job
for there's a presense constraint an ad
job for starts only after job 1 is
finished okay so to warm up let me show
you a to approximation that's known
since the 60s and this is due to Graham
and the algorithm is as easy as it could
be you just do everything just radially
so you following you look at the first
time unit and you stare at your jobs and
you you look at which job could you
possibly run at the first time unit this
job one who doesn't have any precedence
constraint
incoming and job nine doesn't have any
incoming precedence constraints then you
stare a little longer at your jobs but
then now you see that actually all the
other jobs they depend either on one or
nine so I leave this the last time the
last not empty and I just go to the next
time and I schedule maybe job two and
and so on and you see just everything
greedily and so until you're done if you
look at this then you see that you we
didn't do things optimally this is the
same instances on the last slide and
there is this this long chain here and I
probably should have started with that
one earlier so it's kind of the greedy
algorithm didn't see that coming
okay so now why is this what is this a
to approximation
okay so let's stare at the last job that
that got finished and let's wonder what
why didn't we schedule this one earlier
so in particular let's look at a time
unit where we had one slot idle like
here then actually this job must be
dependent on some job scheduled at the
time and now you wonder why did I not
schedule this guy earlier well I I look
at the last time unit that where I
didn't use all the machines and again
there is not going to be some job that
actually he depends on and it's on so
you can backtrack and you can
reconstruct a chain of jobs a chain as
it's a sequence of jobs where one
depends on the next on the on the
previous one so you can recover a chain
of jobs that covers all the time units
where you didn't use on with all the
machines okay now the length of any
chain is a lower bound on the optimum
because you know even just to schedule
that chain you'll need opt time units on
the other hand if you look at the
remaining time units the remaining time
you know it's I have used all the
machines that again is a lower bound on
the optimal because like even if I
away all my precedence constraints
that's how much time I need then you add
up that you cover the whole time all
right a few algorithm and you add up
both of those you know different time
units and and you you get that this is
that most what you can shave off some
factor that depends on on em and that
goes to zero by just observing that you
you don't need to double count like the
jobs in your chain they you know if you
count the job in the you know chain then
it's not gonna appear again as in that
second lower bound but okay so this is
kind of what you can do you have any
question so now this is a factor of two
and well you can get a factor of su then
the next question is can I get a factor
of 1.9 maybe I can do that if the greedy
algorithm you know doesn't do better
then maybe you've right on someone in
your program and you try to do something
with that so that's just the natural
approach and you know if if you sit down
five minutes and you have to write down
something your program then probably you
will have come up with this linear
program or with one that looks very
similar okay so what are the decisions
to make the decisions that you want to
make is like where to schedule every job
so you would probably introduce some
decision variable xjt which is supposed
to be one if you run that job J at time
T and then there are the usual
constraint said that you're writing down
like every job has to be scheduled at
one time you need for every time unit at
every time you can schedule at most M
jobs and now you kind of well how you
write on the the presense constraints
maybe you need to think a little bit
about that one option is that you look
at and every pair IJ so that I has to
come before J and then you add a net
every time T and then you can write down
that the
action with which you have scheduled I
between time 1 and T that has to be at
least as large as the fraction which of
J's that you have scheduled between 1
and T plus 1 so something there is a you
know if the X JT are integral this is
going to do the job unit length jobs yes
yeah they're not you know thing then you
know things are getting more complicated
we had a talk you know that was the
rectangles and do you know the height is
a most most Abbott's on okay good so is
this going to be better than the factor
of two unfortunately not it's not really
hard to construct some counter example
some instance but we're gonna learn a
little bit from it and here we go
imagine you you have your jobs which are
arranged in blocks so imagine these are
these are M plus one jobs these are the
next n plus one jobs and in one block
the jobs they all have to finish before
you can start with any job in the next
block so if you now look at it at an
integral schedule you need to time units
to finish one block but if you now think
about what the linear program can do the
linear program essentially needs 1 plus
1 over m time units to like fractionally
schedule the jobs so it can run to the
same extent it will run every job in the
first blog and then it'll run a little
bit of the of all the jobs in the first
block in the second time unit and then
immediately kind of in the same time
units start with the next block and if
you stare at this long you know then you
see that actually this is a valid a
piece of lewisham and we already see one
problem that even if you have a job i
and a job j and they depend on each
other if you look at the RP solution
their support will overlap so it kind of
has to be ok so there is a gap between
you know two time units versus one plus
one over n time units so this is
basically again that too much
some constant over an entire gap so also
Dia P is not going to do better okay
so aa little bit of bad news things kind
of get worse in the sense that the
question was answered like seven years
ago but the usual suspect that actually
under under very end of the unique games
conjecture there is no better than to
approximation algorithm even if you
assume that the jobs all have unit
length so the we we are in our setting
with unit length jobs okay however often
in scheduling the number of jobs it's
it's it's very large compared to the
number of machines which in theory we we
like to consider for that case that well
what happens if the number of my
machines is constant and you know just
the number of of jobs is unbounded and
in fact it's in the good old book of
Garey and Johnson there's still the open
question whether if you have only three
machines and you know the rest of the
setting is as I described it is this an
np-hard problem and this is still
unknown
still not seeing the solution in this
talk yeah so this is on the original
list of was it 25 open problems there
are now many open like 2.5 depending how
you count like graph isomorphism kind of
but anyway so there's only very small
fractional number of job problems open
and there is a nice survey of sermonette
working uh we also this the question
even whether there is a pitas for this
problem with three machines this is this
is listed as a part of a proper number
one okay and so the the result that we
are showing is that actually you kind of
can get that Peters so you can get a 1
plus epsilon approximation the way you
do that
is you take that in your program that I
showed you you throw it in your favorite
LP hierarchy and after some weird number
of rounds you get that down to that 1
plus epsilon integrality gap so the
number of rounds it's a little more than
quasi poorly logarithmic like the
epsilon at the m kind of a Piercy and
the constant it's you know though the
Rockets usually okay but you know
morally this is like a QP toss it's like
a QQ Peters it's a quasi okay
anyway so the running time that you're
getting some some almost quasi pulley
quasi-polynomial running time okay okay
so the message is that the linear
program after some strengthening by your
favorite P hierarchy can actually do the
job okay
any questions
which says one doesn't ask in polite
company no it's there is an R M divided
by epsilon square here I believe yeah
okay fine good okay so the goal will be
think of the number of machines as being
a constant epsilon is being some small
consonant now we will want to study what
the achieve that sure are the Adams
hierarchy is doing with our linear
program okay so if you haven't worked
with these LP hierarchies I try to give
you you know a gentle introduction the
the general motivation is the following
that you have some linear relaxation for
your favorite draw problem and the
linear relaxation is not not good enough
it doesn't do the job that it should be
so imagine like this is a like a poor
visualization this is your linearization
K and this is the convex all of the
integral points so these black dots they
suggest the integral points and you know
your linearization is kind of far away
now what you want to do is are you want
to get make that linearization stronger
one way like a systematic way is you
introduce some extra variables in a
systematic way and now you can you can
you can then write down some other
system of constraints that's going to
involve your original constraints and if
you look back at the projection on the
original variables then the feasible
region that you're getting it's going to
be stronger than the one that you had
before don't be strictly stronger okay
and now these these hierarchies they
they will have a parameter and as you
increase the parameter the reacts ation
gets stronger and stronger
but also the running time that that
you'll need to solve that that hierarchy
is going to blow up and the latest after
your number of variables many iterations
your hierarchy if you project it down in
the original space it will
Society describe the convex hull of the
the integer solutions okay so slightly
more concrete if this is like in
generality this is your linear
relaxation it's like this is a polytope
it's going to have all the X so that you
know some linear system of inequalities
is satisfied actually it's going to be
important that that you assume that the
variables are between 0 and 1 which is
typically the case for us so this is for
0 1 relaxations then so somatically what
you do is you take every subset of
variables of size at most T and T is
going to be the parameter that your
hierarchy depends on and you you
introduce a new new variable Y of that
index set and then this variable is
should represent that joint probability
that all the variables in capital I r1
at the same time so you kind of you you
look at the like the joint distributions
on on every subset of I variable and
there is a there's an explicit
mechanical way how you can write down
live a big-leaguer program of size
essentially into the T with with that
enter the T many variables and what you
will get is that whenever you only look
at T many variables the solution that
you have will look like it is actually
in the convex hull of integral solutions
so yeah so this is like a cinematic way
of getting things wrong or any question
okay so you you can see that there is a
lot of space on the slide but I'm not
putting I don't put how you bright down
those constraint it's usually if you see
the first time it's not helpful and if
you have seen it before then
you know why put it again I promise you
there is an explicit way mechanical way
or we can just write down the
constraints and but I want to explain
you the properties that we get and we
essentially we only use the properties
as the black box so here is kind of the
key property that we'll need and this is
called like inducing on one variable if
you look at the literature okay so let's
say this is give some some solution for
your tea round sure are the Adams
hierarchy and okay so and let's say
let's imagine there is one variable that
you have one of the original variables
and it's strictly the value of that
variable strictly between 0 and 1 then
what is true is that there will be two
other Sharada adams solution that i call
z 0 and z 1 with the property that y is
is a convex combination of those two
guys and that 0 has that variable that
we said that has a 0 and that one has
that variable that we stared at being
one and there is an explicit way how you
can get these that these vectors that 0
n entered 1 now
now these two other sharers sure are the
atoms solutions they are not going to be
feasible 40 rounds of real are the atoms
but they are still feasible for t minus
1 rounds of Shannara atoms and there's a
mechanical way or we can practice down
and it's a little bit the way or you can
think about this is like if your
probability distribution there's some
event that has 4
ability between zero and once it's kind
of possible that happens it's possible
that it doesn't happen then you can
write it as a convex combination of two
probability distributions you know in in
in in one your event doesn't happen in
the other one it happens so this is not
not a consistent probability
distribution but you can do the same
thing here
okay so now again if you look at the the
literature then very often in other
areas you will see your sentence like oh
we want to induce on some variable being
one and what that actually means is that
you you have a tear on Charlie Adam's
solution some variable has a value
strictly between 0 & 1
and now if you now imagine you're
replacing this vector with this one then
what happens is that suddenly that
variable that you have seared it it
becomes 1 okay you still have a valid
sure the atom solution value for one
round less and that variable is 1 yeah
so this is this is a little bit like you
know if you're a Harry Potter fan you
have your magic 1 and you see some
variable being between 0 & 1 then you
can say be 1 then suddenly it becomes 1
so yeah it's a nice way for your grand
grand application to write it that way
anyway okay so this is this is a
mechanism that we're gonna use
there is one technicality that's kind of
I don't want to say trivial yeah you
know but you I hope you see what I mean
is that actually if you do this
conditioning if you condition on some
variable being 1 if you look at other
variables that were not involved what
happens with them
if their value was 0 then the
conditioning is not going to change that
right so if you okay if you have a
probability distribution and you
condition on some event then some other
event if it had probability 0 before
then it doesn't happen that suddenly the
the probability goes above the oh okay
same
this is going to be very crucial it's a
it's a little softer in the echo okay oh
good so this is these are actually this
actually all the properties that that
we're gonna use for a surety Adams okay
so now we can come to the to the actual
algorithm now we're we're we're we're
back to a scheduling problem we have n
jobs with precedence constraints they
have unit time with their machines so
we're back to that setting so let's say
T is our time horizon imagine we guess
what they Optum time horizon is we try
everything out and so what we're doing
is we we split the time horizon into two
equal intervals into Twitter intervals
of equal length then we can we split
those intervals into intervals of
equaling that's on so we're getting a
nice binary family of intervals
partitioning you're at your time horizon
okay so that's gonna have like log T
which is basically basically log and
many many levels and okay so we we solve
that Charlie Adams hierarchy forty
rounds apply to a linear program T is
gonna be that weird quasi fully
logarithmic factor okay and now we look
at the the support of the jobs in that
you're a leeadams solution meaning that
there's going to be some job J if we
look at job J then the sure re adams
solution it's going to schedule it with
with some fraction here with some
fraction here and so on you know this
took the support it doesn't have to be
consecutive it doesn't have to be an
interval and now we imagine the
following now we put the time being we
assign the jobs to the smallest interval
in our binary family with the whole
support fits and what our algorithm is
going to do is then
if the whole support was in one of the
intervals in the binary family then our
algorithm is going to schedule that job
somewhere here somewhere in that
interval and the algorithm will be
recursive in the sense that it will
start with the small intervals in the
binary family it will schedule the job
all the jobs that are contained in here
and then it will go up and then it will
schedule the jobs that only fit into the
the the larger intervals in that binary
decomposition the intuition is that like
this job they have kind of more
flexibility to move around and these are
kind of like more restrictive okay good
there's one observation that is gonna be
important let me go back to I think one
can actually see it already from that
greedy Evan that I showed at the very
beginning right okay so this is this is
that greedy algorithm due to Graham and
we showed the analysis the makespan is
going to be at most two times the
optimum but you can say a little bit
more the makespan is going to be at most
the optimum plus the length of the
longest chain so actually we did prove
that which obviously a most whopped
but if I could if you would have an
instance where the chains are shorter
than opt you would actually get
something better so if all the chains
would have length only epsilon times up
then we wouldn't have to do all that
you know messy business with try Adams
and so on okay so long chains are a
problem and the our error needs to find
a way to deal with long chains just the
have very high-level idea is that you
use the sure Ali Adams solution use that
conditioning mechanism to fix some jobs
in long chains and then you make some
progress we
are here yes okay any any any more
questions so okay now things are getting
a little bit more technical so these are
please ask if something is unto you okay
so this is my this is my binary
decomposition of depth like lauki or log
n and what I'm doing is I look at the
first of those levels the the largest of
those intervals and I look at the first
one essentially log log n square many of
those intervals think of this as being
morally as being like a big constant if
it was a big consented yeah
the Ronny Campbell look nice about
anyway okay so what I want to do is I
want to use this that conditioning
mechanism that Charlie Adams provides me
to actually enforce that all the jobs
that I had assigned to these logged log
and Lovelock and square many many levels
that these don't have any long chain and
I'm going to explain this on the next
slide what I mean with that okay so but
imagine that at least for those are for
the set of jobs that are assigned to the
top top intervals they don't contain
long chains I can get that now let's
let's see then what I want to do is I
want to create a gap there are other
scheduling algorithms where you do the
same kind of game it's you have some
longer jobs some shorter jobs then you
want to create a gap between them we're
trying something similar here and the
length of the jobs is the same but it's
kind of like how they are spread out in
so in terms of support is going to be
different
okay so just by some counting argument I
can find a certain number of layers in
my decomposition where I don't have too
many jobs and I can I just throw them
away okay
okay now well actually I cannot really
throw jobs away the end of the day I do
have to schedule them but I imagine I I
have a little pile of jobs that I I
didn't manage to schedule then at the
very end of the algorithm I look at my
valid schedule with all the other jobs
now I take the job that I had to throw
away I can find some time unit where you
know I can insert an extra private time
unit and then plug that job in there so
for every one job that I'm throwing away
it's going to cost me an extra one time
unit at the end to just fix everything
and repair the schedule okay good so
there are some jobs that I'm going to
throw away and now I said that it will
be a recursive algorithm now what I do
is I look at the largest interval below
the the levels that I've been throwing
away and here this again looks like like
the original instance there is some time
horizon and I look at all the jobs whose
support is fully contained in that time
horizon and that again is some separate
instance and I recursively call my
algorithm and schedule everything so
they are going to be scheduled
recursively somewhere and I do that like
for every of those time for every of
those intervals that are directly below
the levels that have been throwing away
okay so if this there's one remark I
should make is that if you okay so until
until this step I have been doing some
conditioning on that you're a leeadams
solution and now i recurse and what I'm
doing is I give a copy of my sure the
atom solution after the after the
conditioning I give a copy to this one
and a copy to this one and copy to this
one the point is that what is done
afterwards here the conditioning will be
in will be parallel in a potentially
inconsistent way
so the point is that yeah because I only
have some number T of rounds to you know
Anya so and in particular there's a
problem there's a potential problem
maybe if I recursively schedule like
this sub instance here it's like that
red job ends up like at the end this job
ends up at the beginning but maybe I
needed some space between those jobs to
squeeze in some some other jobs there
are dead of further up in the
decomposition so it's not clear that
this is going to make any any sense so
far okay okay
so okay and because at the very end I
kind of have to show that I can squeeze
in those jobs that are in the top levels
with the support is kind of spread out I
have to show that I can I can I can
squeeze those in between my recursively
scheduled jobs that had a shorter
support okay um good there is yeah the
one thing I want to show you is how we
can actually reduce the length of chains
okay so let's let's go little back a
little bit and imagine okay imagine here
you have billions of jobs they are all
assigned to to this very topic interval
and in particular what it means their
support or kind of crosses this middle
line here and how could I guarantee you
that those billions of jobs they don't
have contain a long chain it may be the
K is a priori okay but if that happens I
do the following okay so let's say these
are my billions of jobs and in
particular have having a long chain
means that there is some job where a lot
of jobs depend on this guy so let's say
it's this one so there's some job and it
has some fraction of the time arises
many jobs dependent on him and the
support of all those jobs it crosses
like the same time unit now what I can
do is so this job here it's with some
positive fraction throughout the atom
schedules it in in the left part and
with some positive fraction it schedules
it in the right part so I can now
condition on this this job here
scheduled let's say fully in the right
part and if you now imagine what happens
to the other jobs that depend on him
they will also be fully scheduled in
that right half the reason is that now
this variable is like this variable
being here is set to one and it's still
at least a valid LP solution so it's
like all the other very variable or the
other jobs that depend on him they will
be scheduled fully in this interval just
by having a valid at P solution and no
just imagine some variable has been set
to one okay and now you just repeat this
game until you know the dependence of
those jobs is below the threshold that
you want to have and you do some
counting which is boring so we can make
it I just gave that okay bad yeah okay
so what what we can do here is let me go
back to where is a decent picture it's
okay yeah we can go back we can we can
we can get that all the jobs that that
still remain and whose support is is
only contained in those like top
intervals they don't contain long chains
okay we could get rid of the long chains
if jobs wearing long chains that
actually by conditioning they would have
you know move down in that decomposition
I mean why don't you go to the right
type in why didn't you condition on the
line given in that case ah there's no
reason why you go to why you have to go
to the right you good one side I mean
you also could have said let's get one
job that has a lot of incoming
precedence constraints and then let's
condition hit him on going to the left
the only problem is like okay he has a
lot of like outgoing presidents
constraints if you condition him like
going on the left that doesn't
necessarily have any effect would you
just say well you know that it doesn't
become infeasible so the point is that
okay if the shirali Adams hierarchy has
a has some variable between strictly
between 0 & 1 then you know that there
is a surety Adams solution one round
less where the variable is actually 1 so
it's in some sense like when you stop
she already Adams you have already
looked in all directions it's like all
the possible conditions you have already
tried them out and they they will all be
feasible
like okay here's how I understand that
the algorithm works maybe I'm totally
wrong but I thought one long chain you
pick the guy in the middle of the chain
and you say yes has to go to left or the
right you try both conditionings you
don't have to try just you you just
trust that show Ali Adams you know did
everything the right way you don't have
to try think you could say you're going
to try every possible conditioning for
one right if you pick you pick number of
rounds variables and then you condition
every possible conditioning this would
cost you extra time but that's not what
you're doing it's not what what we need
we don't we don't have to do that okay
okay good okay so okay we can get rid of
long chains at least yeah for the for
those like top level jobs good okay so
okay but there's a the second part of
the problem
so the situation may look like this
there are some top-level jobs these are
jobs where the support is really spread
out and there are some bottle bottom
level jobs where the support was can
contained in like a tiny interval and we
recursively schedule those guys but
there are dependencies between them
potentially so in in particular some top
never jobs may depend on plenty of those
bottom level jobs and it may have you
know like plenty of those bottom level
jobs may depend on him and we
recursively schedule those bottom level
jobs actually independently so we have
actually no guarantee we're in this
interval like this guy is going to be
scheduled we have no guarantee we're in
this interval this guy is scheduled okay
so we're going to be pessimistic and we
will we will kind of assume the worst
case and the worst case is that if you
look at some top level jobs and you look
at all
the bottom level jobs that he depends on
we assume that kind of they are all like
scheduled at the very end of their
respective intervals and we call the
maximum of those interval ends it's
release time and we look at all the
bottom level job bottom level jobs that
depend on J and the beginning of the
minimum beginning of any interval of
these guys we call that the deadline of
of J and now in some sense we can cut
down the interaction at the bottom that
the top job has with those bottom jobs
we can we can cut it down to just
staring at the release time at the
deadline and this guy just has to be
scheduled between the release time and
the deadlines then it's going to satisfy
the other precedence constraints between
him and the bottom jobs just to reduce
the complexity a little bit okay you can
already see a potential problem that if
this is the support of that you're on
the LM solution potentially after
conditioning is that there might have
been some overlap so some fraction of
this job maybe would have been scheduled
in in that interval and now we kind of
we lose that fraction so we can't use
that fraction okay now if you we did
create this gap and if you're wondering
how much that gap is then actually it's
the biggest of those those bottom
intervals it would fit a quasi poly
logarithmic number of times though I
sorry a pulley logarithmic number of
times into this into every of those
those top intervals so there's some poly
log gap that's got to be enough okay so
we still have to show how can we how can
we schedule all the other top jobs in
the gaps that remain and we we're going
to do that in in in in two phases in the
first phase we were generous
we ignore all the precedence constraints
between different top jobs so that we're
not going to lose too much in that phase
and then we will kind of fix the
schedule and also respect the presense
constraints among top jobs okay okay so
okay uh yeah it's okay it's a little bit
okay now let's do yeah okay for the for
a moment imagine imagine the top we have
to get rid of that we have to assign the
top jobs for the moment ignore the
precedence constraints so you have unit
length jobs there are some slots left
after the recursion and those unit
length jobs there are some precedence
constraints and there are some deadlines
like algorithmically how could you do
that
there are some scheduling experts in the
first world either matching or greedy
yes both works ok yes yes so it's you
yeah it's a bipartite matching thing or
if you do everything with early step not
first probably you could with other
greedy type algorithms it's it
supporting it's a it's a nice polynomial
properly yeah
okay okay in particular well okay
in particular the following you have
this rowdy atom solution enter Charlie
atom solution particular it's a fracture
solution it it will induce a fractional
matching which you can nicely use if you
wanna have a matching this argument
there's one problem is that you can
think about this as follows if if you
have you have your jobs on this side if
you like set up that bipartite matching
problem and there are some slots there
are some slots on the right side and
like somewhere here is some job J and
it's possible that it's gonna be
assigned to some some slots so it has
some neighborhood and it's like you have
this variable like you have this your
are the atoms solution it's gonna tell
you that okay there's some some fraction
with some factor it goes to 2 sometimes
unity and you know that you know this is
essentially it's a fractional matching
so you know that actually there is a way
of scheduling the top jobs there is some
there's some problem that actually we
are gonna cut off some of the slots at
the end these ones here so we're kind of
losing something in that fractional
matching there's kind of a variant of
Hearts theorem that helps you like if
you if you have a perfect matching now
you're cutting off parts of your
neighborhood like how many how many left
hand side jobs can you notice
that's essentially by the mat the worst
by how much like the neighborhood shrink
and okay so you can apply that that
little theorem so you can look at some
subset of your jobs and you can see by
how much would the neighborhood shrink
now you can observe that actually since
this like all all your top jobs they
contain one of those like interval big
interval endings and beginnings so you
cannot have only you only losing the
slots of contained in one tiny interval
/ big interval well at most two tiny
intervals / big interval but they are
like pulley logarithmic lee many tiny
intervals in every big interval so that
means you're only losing a 1 over pulley
lock fraction okay that was a little bit
fast but it's not too hard thing just
staring long enough as holds theorem and
counting like how many jobs you could
not assign okay okay so that means there
is a very limited loss it's just a
pulley lock fraction of of all my jobs
that I'm losing at least if I'm allowed
to ignore the precedence constraints
okay yeah okay so now I kind of have to
fix that and so this is the last thing
that I have to show this is actually
gonna be the well the last slide with
some action on it so this is the problem
that I have to solve there are some jobs
now with precedence constraints so these
are my top jobs they're free students
constraints they're gonna have yeah
there's some chain lengths that I can
control they have release times
deadlines and there's some remaining
capacity curve that's kind of left after
after I recursively scheduled on the
bottom jobs okay
and I know that
well I have enough slots so that if I
wouldn't have precedence constraints I
could you know schedule all the jobs
okay so yeah let's go back to the
question and okay I have unit length
jobs release times deadlines without the
precedence constraints I could use
matchings or I could use greedy what
what type of greedy algorithm this EDF
earlier said like first very well-known
poly policy for the scheduling people in
the audience I guess so what you're
doing is that if you have jobs and they
have some deadlines then you just run
them and you always take take the jobs
that have the latest deadline and for
the people in the audience or currently
writing ten year letters that's kind of
probably what you are you schedule here
and your letters as well okay so the
good news is that this is a polynomial
time algorithm and it's an optimum
policy if you don't have precedence
constraints just from the intuition what
do you think happens if you have
precedence constraints but I can
guarantee you that the the chains in
your precedents that are short
it's probably not an optimum policy any
more but the short of the chains the
kind of more closer to being optimal it
gets right and that intuition is right
and it's it's not really hard to prove
yeah but now it's going to be crucial
that we can actually get the that
maximum chain length see it's gonna be a
fraction of my jobs and I can make that
fraction as small as I like and I pay
with that just by by losing Charlie
Adams rounds so I can I can make that
maximum chain length as small as
possible and now I just run early step
on first okay so what I do is to be
precise it's it's it's the following so
I started at the first time unit and I
just I take the job with a minimum
deadline and I just schedule it if it
ever happens that I manage to know that
I don't manage to finish a job in time
then I just I just throw it away then
the end of the day I just I count how
high my pile of discarded jobs is okay
the analysis is going to be very similar
to that classical analysis that you can
find in any scheduling book there they
prove that EDF is optimal here we prove
that EDF is almost optimal and the
almost depends on the length of your
chains okay okay so now let's say you
run earliest a time first and it happens
that you know there's going to be some
time interval where you have to discard
a ton of jobs a ton let's say is K okay
and now you can backtrack you can
backtrack and you can go to the last of
those intervals where you had a lot of
idle time a lot of idle time for me
means more than the length of the
longest chain many idle times okay so in
particular every interval between did
not have
and at most see many idle times and now
you can do some reasoning the reasoning
is as follows it's not possible that you
have a job somewhere here that had a
release time that was released here
because that guy I could have scheduled
him here because I have enough idle
times right okay so if you have okay
that the point is if between between the
release time of a job and the time that
it was either finished or discarded if
you have more than see many idle times
you you kind of get a contradiction
because then you would have scheduled it
that guy alia because the length of the
longest chain is see it's kind of an
argument that's very similar to what I
showed you like on the second slide on
the Indian Alice's for the greedy
algorithm anyway so you get some kind of
contradiction because you know that you
know the number of those intervals I'm
see actually cannot exceed K and then
you get some model K and that's going to
be enough I'm sorry that things are
going to be a little bit messy yeah yeah
those numbers aren't really important
you do the accounting but things are
gonna work out smoothly okay that's kind
of the end of the technical part there
are some nice open problems now it's
wide open problem less actually so the
number of rounds that I needed it was
like log in to the log log N and there
wasn't a recent improvement by by by
Sushma you can actually get things down
to poorly log many rounds that gives you
an actual was the polynomial running
time by essentially doing the recursion
in a smarter way it's still open whether
you could use just some constant
depending on epsilon and M many sure are
the Adams rounds probably if you want to
get that your algorithm has to be very
different it's kind of whenever you
recurse you probably have to lose
a login somewhere and finally a nice
open problem is what happens if your
jobs are not unit length jumps what if
they have arbitrary processing times
some of the arguments still work some
don't and in particular if you know that
you have enough slots for you for your
jobs that's not enough to be to argue
that you can actually you know schedule
all your jobs if the running times are
different but anyway yeah think I'm
finishing five minutes early but yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
what exactly
millions and discard those jobs you
records on the bottom it's important yes
you first to the conditioning then you
throw away like some middle layer the
jobs in some middle layer and then you
do the recursion when you see condition
you mean on you would yes yes it's like
if this number is too big for you if
like there's like a too long change here
then you would like condition on this
guy be click going let's it to the right
side yes the jobs you looked at the
chain length of the nose and then candy
yes so how much of the I guess by now
only quasi-polynomial is given by
actually trying to get a scheme rather
than not saying I give you have machines
is that something that there's enough
technology there to just actually make a
polynomial ending a 1.99 in polynomial
time it's not coming out of the
algorithm no that would require some
aches or thoughts
although integrality guts and
unfortunately others with the concept
that Wow I'm not aware of any and I
haven't really tried
any other questions
Bartlett's 10,000
[Applause]